we're in Paris where world leaders of
the UN climate conference are scrambling
to reach a decision on how to limit co2
emissions for the 21st year in a row
it's not time to be wishy-washy many are
looking at corporations to be the
knights in shining green armor and save
the day
even though corporations are one of the
main reasons there's so much carbon in
the atmosphere so can big business save
us from climate collapse or are they
more interested in saving face and their
profits
what is sky mining sky mining is the
world's the profitable way of actually
taking co2 out of the atmosphere more
profitable than taking it out of the
ground
exactly I'm really excited to learn that
BMW is going to be phasing out all gas
powered vehicles it's a question of time
wouldn't be more sustainable to you know
not add so much sugar into all the
drinks which is sustainably giving
people diabetes around the world we
offer choice it's striking to me that
one of the main sponsors here is a
company like Dow Chemical which has
contributed to honeybee colony collapse
and put food security in danger thanks
to all of its pesticides like isn't that
a little bit of a conflict of interest
we are focusing on mobility in an urban
environment yeah but I think you'll find
that the fact that that Dow are now
prepared but that you know put their
names of any to put their brand to
events like this means that they believe
that their sustainability policy is in
line with what we would regard as
executive or this is a good opportunity
for them to green wash their brand in
the future
sustainable urban living in public
transportation I think you look
completely correct in that statement a
lot of people actually think it tastes
not only better than a soy burger but
better than a meat burger made from a
cow no it's no in-n-out burger I'm a mom
I have a 14 year old and a 10 year old
yeah I want this world to be around for
them well it won't be I mean actually
your kid's gonna have kids but their
kids can definitely not have kids can
you ever convince a company like
coca-cola to accept less profit I think
companies like coca-cola are beginning
to realize that there is a sweet spot
between profit and and and social
responsibility
I got banks we got sent the city of
Gothenburg what's awesome let's do this
I was for climate change baby if this
whole planet Earth thing does not work
out does coca-cola have a Mars plan well
you know what they just found water on
Mars so I think we should all maybe have
a motor plant there vertical farming
offers a lot of benefits to this really
malfunctioning food system but you gotta
plug this in somewhere right everyone
seemed to have an easy solution but I
did find someone who was willing to
think bigger picture the important thing
is to see it from both perspectives
because we are trapped within a
capitalistic kind of system that has
been operating for many years and it
worked at one point but now with the
population that we have in the kind of
system we're unable to sustain this
current way of life what would you do if
you had the budget of the coca-cola
company and your task was to become
sustainable obviously a lot of these
corporations I self-interested and it's
all about the power games I think I
would give it back
the people in many ways and kind of
invest in a service and an organization
that was actually willing to give back